the chaos at kabul airport last august
symbolized for many the pain and failure
of the 20-year war by the us and its
allies
with the sudden collapse of the afghan
government crowds stormed the airport
trying to get out
some desperately hung onto the fuselages
of departing planes only to fall to
their deaths
twenty-year-old market stall worker
suleiman safi was one of them
he told his mother he wanted to earn
more money to support the family and pay
for his younger brother's medical
treatment
he said to me mother they are taking
people abroad for free and if you allow
me i will go somewhere and make money
for my brother's treatment
i said no this is a lie don't do this he
left anyway
thousands more people besieged the
outside of the airport held back by
taliban fighters
hayatuddin hyatt worked for american
contractors as a security guard and
wanted to be flown out
i went to the airport twice with my kids
but couldn't get through the crowds to
the gates so i came back home
for many hopes of getting out faded with
the departure of the last military
transport late on the night of august
the 30th
it's the helmets and the body armor an
event marked by thunderous taliban
gunfire into the skies that began as we
were on air
since then with international support
and technical help airport operations
have been restored with the resumption
of some chartered and scheduled flights
even when flights out of afghanistan are
back to normal hurdles will remain for
people wanting to take them there are
problems getting passports and visas
then finding a country willing to take
them in
many like hayet are still waiting for a
special visa that will entitle him to
settle with his family in the u.s
there's no work here and my kids have no
future my daughters used to go to school
but now they sit at home
three months after the end of the u.s
presence here the sudden departure and
the trauma caused by it will likely be
felt for months if not years to come
rob mcbride al jazeera herrat
afghanistan